nous on va se déplacer dans la
bibliothèque de france 3 pourraient les
rejoindre tiphaine sypher qui nous
attend parce que les vacances d'été
c'est pô dans quelques jours
nos enfants vont partir comme nous en
vacances en a tous besoin et on peut
peuvent carrément de partir dans l'
aventure de la lecture pourquoi pas
parce que vous avez saisi décidé de nous
présenter des livres qui on va dire
sortent un peu du cadre c'est ça tu es
fun oui parfois pour faire rêver les
jeunes lecteurs les auteurs décident de
déborder de la page et du coup ils vont
par leur éditeur et parfois et bien les
éditeurs leur donne carte blanche alors
c'est le cas de raphaël baud tient d un
médiateur jeunesse franc comtois 1
puisque sa maison d'édition s'appelle
chocolat jeunesse édition et c'est pour
ça aussi je voulais vous en parler alors
il a donné carte blanche à adele tariel
et jérôme peyrat pour ce monde perdu
c'est un livre très surprenant alors le
héros un petit mousse se retrouve
embarqué sur un galion de pirates à la
recherche d'un trésor mais lui il craint
surtout un énorme monstre à tentacules
qui risque de menacer le bateau alors sa
mission c'est de tout dessiné donc de
dessiner les tempêtes de dessiner les
mauvaises rencontres et vous le voyez ce
livre est bien se déplie comme un paquet
cadeau et à l'intérieur et bien ce n'est
pas un trésor que vous allez découvrir
mais bien une civilisation perdue c'est
vraiment un très joli livre je ne vous
raconte pas évidemment la fin de
l'histoire mais je vous le conseille
pour les enfants à partir de 6 ans nous
on aime le monde perdu da dalt ariel et
jérôme peyrat le deuxième album il
raconte lui aussi l'histoire d'une quête
celle d'un trésor perdu cette fois ci et
là c'est pour les enfants va dire à
partir de 7 ans est ce qu'ils ont besoin
ou non d'une carte tiffen et oui parce
que le livre lui-même s'appelle ma
fabuleuse carte aux trésors et c'est un
livre objet vous le voyez à l'intérieur
il y a à la fois un livre une carte et
même un miroir puisque on vous propose
de devenir le héros de cette histoire
alors guillaume guéraud et renault perd
1 on imagine
et que vous avancez dans l'histoire tout
en avançant sur la carte et c'est un
vrai un travail littéraire il ne s'agit
pas juste d'un jeu c'est un roman
d'aventurés et vous croisez énormément
de personnages tous très originaux alors
le trappeur jack johnson vous avez un
lecteur fou qui s'appelle buck hausse
qui est une aventurière qui s'appelle
julie à guirlandes
alors je vous conseille de bien lire
toutes les petites instruction avant de
commencer votre quête
et je conseille aussi aux parents de
participer parce que c'est très drôle
vous le voyez les illustrations sont
magnifiques et c'est bourré de petites
références et évidemment et bien une
fois que vous aurez mener votre quête
vous pourrez trouver le trésor grâce à
cette carte on dit jamais deux sans
trois ce sera le tout dernier livre
parce qu'on a un peu pressés par le
temps
tiphaine comme on a tous hâte de partir
en vacances
j'ai l'impression que les livres hors
format que vous nous proposez nous
emmène également vers un voyage
sympathique je me trompe ou pas oui
alors cette fois je vous emmène en ville
vous le savez parfois ont choisi d'aller
visiter des grandes mégalopoles c'est le
titre de ce livre c'est un mec plus
anciens de clé à dieudonné publié à la
maison d'édition l'agrume mais je
voulais vous le présenter parce que il
raconté bien l'histoire d'une ville
monde
découverte par les yeux d'un
extraterrestre et pour rendre compte de
ce foisonnement et bien elle a décidé de
faire un livre de trois mètres de haut
alors on lit une page
et puis on déplie c'est quelque chose
d'absolument incroyable vraiment je vous
le conseille c'est fantastique ça plaira
aux enfants à partir de 4 ans et une
fois que vous avez tout lu et bien il
faut chercher les personnages dans la
page c'est vraiment magique c'est un
vrai coup de coeur c'est pour ça que je
voulais vous en parler super merci
tiphaine bonnes vacances et puis rendez
vous surtout à la rentrée pour d'autres
aventures et d'autres choix lecture
médine bourgogne franche comté
parce que vous êtes formidables fancy ça
parce que ce sera aussi le titre de
l'émission voilà très bien pileux